we're talking about tick-tock just you
know somewhat breaking news via Trump
the Trump administration considers
banning tick-tock and other Chinese
social media apps as India has banned
50-plus Chinese apps there and a little
bit of a skirmish on the border there
the FTC and the Justice Department are
looking into allegations that tick-tock
failed to delete accounts for children
under 13 violating a 20-19 agreement and
last week India banned these 59 apps and
that ban could lose by dance eight a six
billion in revenue Mike Pompeo when he
talked about banning Chinese app said
especially tick-tock I don't and the
quote was I don't want to get out in
front of the president but it's
something we're looking at tick tock is
owned by bike dance and it's been
accused of being a security threat
because obviously it's got ties to China
if you're in a business in China you're
in business with CCP which stands for
the Chinese Chinese Communist Party
you know tick-tock of course claims they
operate separately from by dance and the
data centers are located out of China
and that it's not subject to Chinese law
which is absolutely ridiculous
they had 315 million downloads in the
first quarter of 2020 which is
extraordinary their past 2 billion
downloads had the most quarterly
downloads of any app according to sensor
tower analytics 60 percent of the users
are between the age of 16 and 24 and
bizarrely the former head of Disney Plus
Kevin Mayer was named the CEO I don't
know why an American would become the
CEO of a company from a communist
country that seems insane but the inside
scoop is that he felt he should have
been the CEO of Disney so he took this
job which excuse me I'm sure he is
regretting at this point
Alex any thoughts on this story and then
Morgan I'll get yours normally when I
come on the show I have like one strong
opinion about things in this case I'm a
little bit torn one I really do know
it's about Chinese companies in the CCP
and how
the government runs the country and how
it has eyes into everything that happens
commercially because that's how you
censor and kind of run at information
control in the entire country on the
other hand China has banned so many US
services over the years I'm hesitant to
begin to follow suit I wonder if there's
a middle path here that involves looking
into the possible data breach fines
restrictions doubling down on you know
data segregation between different
countries and finding some sort of
middle ground and not just following
suit between a putative League communist
country and an increasingly
nationalistic India it doesn't seem to
be the perch that I like and also I
don't like Mike Pompeo the personal bias
there part of the challenge of this is
you know the Trump administration might
have a reason for doing this that might
have more to do with Morgan to your
point this next generation which is
using tik-tok so now we've got this very
multi-layered nuanced issue do we not
with young people love this platform
well I guess my question is really
what's the responsibility of Apple and
Google for the information that's passed
through I mean to me that seems like
something more in our control as
companies that are actually
headquartered here in the United States
yeah then they let it into the App
Store's of course you know I what
percentage of the users actually know
it's a Chinese app I married nobody no
way the average girl running around
dancing she has no idea that this is
owned what if we did tik talks about how
Tech Talk is owned by by dance what if
we use the platform to spread awareness
of the issue I don't know right I wonder
actually this would be an interesting
test if we did I'm gonna okay listen I
got a lot of followers this is a message
to my followers you know those three
percent of you who are just you know
very enthusiastic let's say one of my
enthusiastic followers please run a
couple of experiments for me I would
like you to run a series of tic TOCs
featuring Tiananmen Square and the
history of Tiananmen Square and let's
see how long it lasts and then I would
like you to inspire everybody to use
the hashtag Tiananmen Square or remember
Tiananmen Square and let's see if we can
trended and to producer Nick and Sir
Charles can we clip this and let's see
if we can Tran Tiananmen Square on
tick-tock and let's put some music
behind it and let's make a really
powerful impactful trending Tiananmen
Square and then we'll find out exactly
who's running tick tock
how's that sound everybody a reasonable
test with it I'll retweet I think my
trolling skills just went to 11 and also
you're never going to China now you're
just you know what actually I've been so
critical Alex it's used it's interesting
you mentioned that my book I translate
into Chinese it's right over here behind
my head on this side and I went to Hong
Kong and I told my friend Mike Savina
who was with me when I was some book
tour there I said you know I'm not going
to mainland China coz I've been a bit
critical and I'm a little concerned
about my safety because I don't want to
be that schmuck who's like the first
American who gets picked up and that was
during the Wow way stuff when Canada had
picked up the the daughter of the CEO
and whatever is some ugliness going on
with that and I was like and and now I
just I did a speaking gig last night in
Hong Kong remote and I was like I don't
think I can go to Hong Kong no not with
a newer law yeah I guess that's all for
me yeah kind of a bummer I you know if
you had to choose a loud tick-tock
knowing the Chinese government had
access to the data let's just assume
that that is 100% certain they have the
keys to the kingdom we know Alex they
have the keys to the kingdom should
putting your you know obvious feelings
about Trump aside and my feelings and
I'm gonna assume Morgan's putting aside
the Trump administration let's just
pretend it was in the Obama
administration or the Kanye
administration in six months should we
ban tik-tok if we knew the government
had access to it yes or no Alex I'm
gonna answer that in the annoying way of
not giving you one more answer here's a
here's a Shanghai no no I'm good I mean
Shanghai was lovely but I not going to
go back until the government is
different the NSA is is grafted onto 18t
and the fiber of the American Internet
it's kind of a generally accepted
statement
and they can just yankin all the data
from the American internet let alone any
magic Laurent to get inside of it
you know again how much faith do you
have in those little legal defenses they
set up
I think the Snowden leaks showed us they
were much more adventurous than they
claimed to be should Europe ban American
apps that are too close to the US
government or the companies that own
they were too close to the US government
I would say no to that I would hope the
answer is no the question then becomes
is the Chinese government such a large
risk that this is required and I think
that my views have changed since the
implementation of the recent security
law in Hong Kong I think now given that
and their their rules that that copán
global I think the answer is probably
yes and my friends love tick tock they
send me tickets all the time I laugh at
them it's lovely I just deleted the app
myself but that probably is the best I
can get on that Jason sorry for being so
Mario why do you stand on it if we knew
that they were looking at it depends on
who I'm solving for you know I think if
I'm solving for like being an American
and democracy etc then yes if I think
that the country in America and the
government really protects us me my
people which I don't believe right now
so then I say no give the people what
they want and it's the responsibility of
the people we pay with our taxes to keep
us safe and figure it out and young
people are probably freaking out right
now to entrepreneurs man if you thought
you wanted to create a competitor now
would be a great time to do it because
I'm gonna put the odds at 80% and by the
way the other thing that I thought was
interesting I and I don't know if you
heard this stuff Morgan was that the
folks at tick-tock were not picking
black people to be featured as dancers
and we're picking white people and
skinny people as bad it was not an early
now certainly a lot of companies have
been caught out recently and a lot of
people are looking like said listen
called outtakes how come a while ago
four kind of like this the algorithm in
the fashion yeah
right so the algorithm is forever
I mean Twitter I love Twitter I love
Jack Dorsey Twitter absolutely suppress
black voices back in the day I don't
know if you guys ever remember a lot of
people used to trend like every night
absolutely you and I talked about I
think on the pod was that there was
actually I heard the internal discussion
about this which was people are confused
by black Twitter because you keep 20
Trent trending stuff that we don't
understand and so we're like can
somebody explain to me why the top 10
things are you know words I don't know
and it's like well you're gonna know
them in about three to six months
because black culture is culture like
exactly let's be honest there was a time
when that was always trend stuff was
always training at like 6 o'clock late
night Twitter and then it's all of a
sudden we stopped trending how not cuz
we stopped talking it's because they
localized it they localized it and then
they made it part of your who you follow
so they did the whole echo chamber thing
[Music]